3 flowers bloomed yesterday
and they draw the flowers 1, 2, 3
6 more bloomed today. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
How many flowers bloomed?
Well 3 yesterday, 6 more today. So you're going to have
the 3 from yesterday, plus the 6 more today.
Well what's 3 plus 6 equal to?
Well 3 plus 6 is the same thing as 6 plus 3 and that's going to be 9.
6 + 1 is 7, 6 + 2 is 8, 6 + 3 is 9.
And it's good to know, just in your head, 6 + 3 is 9. 3 + 6 is 9
or you could even count them......
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Let's do another one.
There were 2 sharks. 1, 2.
3 more sharks came. 1, 2, 3.
How many sharks are there now?
Well there's the 2 that were there before.
Plus the 3 that came.
So, there's 2 plus 3 sharks.
Well, what is 2 plus 3?
Well, 2 + 3 is 5.
2 + 3 is 5 and you could count it. 1,2, 3, 4, 5.
Let's do one more.
A squirrel picked up 7 acorns.
(counting) 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
She picked up one more acorn.
Find out how many acorns she picked up.
Well she picked up the 7.
Plus 1 acorn. So it's going to be 7 plus 1 acorns.
And that is equal to 8.
(counting) 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
You got it right.